Hopes for an overnight return to the old days will certainly be dashed here in France...
...as the lifting of the second national lockdown is said to be a progressive affair,...
...more of a shift into three distinct phases over the next few weeks.
Retail outlets will be able to open from December 1st.
With strict health and safety measures in place,...
...religious establishments will also welcome back worshippers...
...but with limited numbers inside.
Then there are the school holidays.
From December 18th, travel between households should be allowed...
...so people can visit friends and family.
Forms to justify where you are going are unlikely to disappear,...
...but people will no longer be limited to the kilometer surrounding their homes,...
...and once you get there, smaller gatherings are advised.
Above all, authorities want to keep the R rate down,...
...the number of people contaminated by a person suffering from COVID-19.
Scientific data shows that cutting down on interactions...
...keeps contagions and subsequently hospital admissions lower.
The third stage of the lifting of lockdown...
...should come into effect from the beginning of next year...
...when bars, restaurants and sport venues could be back up and running,...
...but that will depend on contamination rates at the end of the holidays.